?
THOSE ARE "5 THINGS" TO KNOW FOR
YOUR "NEW DAY."
DON'T FORGET TO DOWNLOAD THE "5
THINGS" PODCAST EVERY MORNING.
>>> IN A REMARKABLE TIMING
RELEASED OVERNIGHT, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT SAYS IT HAS EVIDENCE
THAT RECORDS WERE LIKELY
CONCEALED AND REMOVED FROM A
STORAGE ROOM AT MAR-A-LAGO IN
ORDER TO OBSTRUCT THE
GOVERNMENT'S INVESTIGATION.
THE FILING INCLUDES THIS PHOTO,
REALLY SOMETHING TO BEHOLD HERE,
A PHOTO OF SECRET AND TOP SECRET
DOCUMENTS INCLUDING HIGHLY
CLASSIFIED COMPARTMENTED
INFORMATION SPREAD OUT ON THE
FLOOR BY THE FBI.
JOINING US NOW IS CNN SECURITY
CORRESPONDENT JOSH CAMPBELL TO
TALK ABOUT THIS.
THAT PHOTO, TELL US WHAT YOU
SEE.
>> THIS RAISES THE PICTURE WORTH
A THOUSAND WORDS APPIES HERE.
WE HEARD THE INFORMATION FROM
COURT RECORDS ABOUT WHAT TYPE OF
MATERIAL THIS IS BUT SEEING IT
THERE LAID OUT, THAT'S PRETTY
STRIKING.
AS WE LOOK AT THIS PHOTO, YOU
SEE THE RED THERE, THE YELLOW
DOCUMENTS, THOSE ARE WHAT ARE
CALLED COVER SHEETS SO YOU HAVE
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION, YOU HAVE
TO PROTECT THAT INFORMATION, SO
YOU HAVE THAT KIND OF COVER
SHEET ON TOP, WHICH IS SUPPOSED
TO SHIELD THAT FROM PEOPLE WHO
MAY NOT HAVE A NEED TO KNOW.
BUT WHAT IS INTERESTING IS IF
YOU LOOK, IT IS HARD TO SEE FROM
THIS PHOTO, BUT WE HAVE BEEN
ZOOMING AROUND, YOU LOOK AT WHAT
IS POTENTIALLY BEHIND THESE
DOCUMENTS, PARTICULARLY THE TOP
SECRET DOCUMENTS, WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HUMAN CONTROLLED
INFORMATION, THOSE LETTERS HCS,
SI, REFERS TO THE GOVERNMENT'S
SIGNALS INTELLIGENCE
CAPABILITIES AND TK, WHICH IS
TALENT KEYHOLE, A GOVERNMENT
SATELLITE PROGRAM.
SO, AGAIN, THAT'S NOT TO SAY
THOSE KIND OF DOCUMENTS ARE
BEHIND THIS, BUT THAT'S WHAT THE
COVER SHEETS WOULD BE COVERING.
SO INCREDIBLY SENSITIVE
INFORMATION AS THIS DOCUMENT
ALLEGED THAT WAS FILED
YESTERDAY.
>> YOU CAN'T MISS IT THAT THIS
IS CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
IT IS VERY CLEAR AND HIGHLY
CLASSIFIED AT THAT, SOME OF
THESE.
TELL US AT THIS POINT IN TIME
BECAUSE THIS FILING WAS PRETTY
REMARKABLE, AND HOW EXPENSE TIFF
EXTENSIVE IT WAS, WHAT HAVE YOU
GLEANED?
>> THIS SHOULD CONCERN THE TRUMP
TEAM, NOT THAT ISN'T CONCERNING
OF ITSELF, BUT ONE PARTICULAR
LINE I WANT TO READ, THE
GOVERNMENT ALSO DEVELOPED
EVIDENCE WHICH THAT'S A NICE
LAWYERLY WAY OF SAYING SOMEONE
IS PROVIDING INFORMATION TO US
THAT GOVERNMENT RECORDS WERE
LIKELY CONCEALED AND REMOVED
FROM THE STORAGE ROOM AND THAT
EFFORTS WERE LIKELY TAKEN TO
OBSTRUCT THE GOVERNMENT'S
INVESTIGATION.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LEARNING ABOUT
THEIR CASE RIGHT NOW.
THE CALL IS COMING FROM INSIDE
THE HOUSE, INSIDE THE BEACH
RESORT, IF YOU WILL.
SOME IS PROVIDING THE FBI
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THE
DOCUMENTS WERE HANDLED AND WHAT
IS CONCERNING FOR TEAM TRUMP, IT
IS NOT SLOPPINESS.
YOU LOOK AT THAT PHOTO OF THESE
CLASSIFIED RECORDS, PARTICULARLY
WITH THE COVER SHEETS, YOU CAN'T
SAY, WELL IT WAS THE MOVERS OR
IT WAS JUST -- WE MISHANDLED
THIS INFORMATION,